joining us today is olaf bonker he heads
the berlin office of the european
council on foreign relations thank you
very much for coming in
american farmers seem to be
for this free trade agreement german
farmers seem to be dead set against it
is that representative
yeah i think it is representative but we
have to be aware it's just a tiny
picture
of the bigger one so
agriculture and and food safety issues
are definitely the headlines in the
newspapers these days
but it's uh not really what ttip is
about
if the two sides are so far apart as far
as opinion goes on food
how are they going to be brought
together at some stage yeah that's
definitely one of the interesting
questions so i think it's uh worth
looking back so uh within the last 10
years so the the export of u.s
agriculture products to europe decreased
immensely so we had a decrease of more
than 50 percent if it comes to grains
poultry for instance more than 70
percent uh less exports from the us to
europe so therefore of course for u.s
farmers this is a big incentive entering
the european market or re-entering so to
say
for european farmers who stepped in
meanwhile in the last 10 years but why
such a big dip over the past 10 years
because the u.s
neglected to to sign a couple of
agreements uh if it comes to food safety
standards in europe and with the
european union to protect their own
market and the europeans developed this
uh tradition further and further so now
they want to enter the market because
it's part of the bigger
trade agreement and now actually of
course we have a big distance so
they want to come together but at very
different levels is this though about
free trade or more about protectionism
i think it's still about free trade uh
but of course it depends on your angle
and your perspective so um
it was
up to now it was not really about
protectionism as such so that but was as
we said on the on the food safety issue
so standards developed because european
consumers for instance demand it to have
higher standards if it comes to a food
regulation
so there are different other
issues in this but if we look at from a
global perspective of course from the
outside outside from europe and the us
this looks pretty much that the two big
markets are protecting and isolating
themselves from the rest what are the
other big issues i suppose financial
regulation would have to be one yeah
definitely financial regulations is one
of the big issues services for instance
make up more than 60 percent of
the trade between the u.s and europe
standards and production of course
it's on the one hand about recognizing
different standards on the other hand
it's about harmonization so these are
two different issues but they have a big
impact of course we've also seen a
report about two families and what they
think on both sides of the atlantic is
the general population actually for this
but it's interest groups that are
holding back these talks i think it's
really hard to say because uh the the
biggest challenge for the public opinion
is that the lack of transparency within
the negotiations so there's hardly any
uh facts on the ground so both
governments decided to
uh to keep this off the record uh so
therefore there's a high interest in
really facts about what is on stake at
the moment and i think uh unless this uh
uh box has been opened so that's really
hard to say what it is but is that going
to change or can it change or does it
have to change of course at some point i
have to open this but the question of
course is how negotiable is the content
we we will be presented so and this is
at the moment so we are negotiating from
the european side with canada the small
or the older brothers so to say to the
ttip negotiations should be signed in
autumn this year
and lawmakers are really scared so
because they think okay it's either take
it or leave it
there's not much room actually for
maneuver so do you see a deal by 2015
hard to say i think it will be a long
hard process of negotiation so but
hopefully i think it's still in the
interest of both sides and the whole
time the wto where does it stand is it
being left out of this yeah definitely
and of course it's legal so
but of course it was first it was
defined as an exceptionalism
to have these kind of free trade
agreements actually of course
multilateral negotiations on the wto
level should be the norm but at the
moment with this ttip actually would set
world standards and then the rest has to
follow mr bunker thank you very much for
the analysis you're welcome